Os lo hemos contando aquí, en VisualPolitik.
Aunque no es habitual oír hablar de ello,
lo cierto es que en los últimos años algunas
cosas están comenzando a cambiar en África.
Desde el año 2000 la mitad de las economías
de mayor crecimiento de todo el planeta han
estado precisamente en este continente.
Y, ojo, según las previsiones del Fondo Monetario
Internacional, en 2018, 6, 6 de las 10 economías
con mayor tasa de crecimiento serán africanas.
Países como Tanzania, Etiopía o Costa de
Marfil se posicionan
a la cabeza del crecimiento mundial.
Ahora bien, África es un continente enorme
formado por 54 países, de tal forma que podemos
encontrar todo tipo de situaciones: países
que crecen mucho y países que no crecen tanto.
Pero hay un caso que destaca por encima de
todos… [y no precisamente porque las cosas
marchen bien por allí]
Sí, estoy hablando de Sudáfrica… durante
mucho tiempo la gran esperanza africana.
Amigos, el sueño de Nelson Mandela de una
Sudáfrica libre y próspera se ha convertido
en una especie de pesadilla.
Durante los últimos años las cosas se han
torcido, el crecimiento ha desaparecido, los
problemas raciales han vuelto y la corrupción
se ha extendido por todo el país.
Incluso el Congreso habla de expropiar sin
compensación la tierra de los blancos.
Ahora bien, en febrero cambió el gobierno
y uno de los hombres más ricos de África
se convirtió en el nuevo presidente.
¿Podrá Sudáfrica recuperar el buen camino,
o estamos por contra ante la gran decepción
africana? ¿Qué diantres pasó para que los
años buenos se terminaran? ¿Corre la población
blanca peligro?
Amigos, en este vídeo trataremos de responder
a estas preguntas. Adelante.
(LA DECEPCIÓN SUDAFRICANA)
Sudáfrica es un país enorme, es tan grande
como la suma de Francia, Alemania, Italia,
Países Bajos y Bélgica, y representa ni
más ni menos que casi una cuarta parte de
todo el PIB del África Subsahariana.
Pues bien, tras el fin del apartheid y la
transición democrática que comenzó en 1994
Sudáfrica vivió una particular edad dorada.
Entre 1998 y 2008 la economía creció de
forma estable, lo que permitió que la clase
media se negra se duplicará y que servicios
tan esenciales como el agua corriente comenzarán
a llegar a la mayor parte de la población.
(Sí, con una economía grande, una democracia
vibrante, una prensa libre y una gran cantidad
de organizaciones civiles, todo parecía listo
para que Sudáfrica lograra dar el salto que
permitiera brindar a todos sus habitantes
- y no solo a la población blanca - una vida
cómoda y propia de un país desarrollado.
En otras palabras, se esperaba que Sudáfrica
se convirtiera en el ejemplo a seguir para
todo el continente)
Sin embargo... esperad un momento, porque
las cosas no siempre resultan como se espera,
y en 2009 todo este proceso terminó.
Desde entonces, amigos, las cosas han ido
de mal en peor.
La economía no crece, el desempleo ha escalado
hasta rozar el 40%
la pobreza ha vuelto a repuntar y las cuentas públicas están hechas un desastre.
Y no solo eso… las últimas medidas anunciadas
por el gobierno y el clima de tensión social
que empieza a respirarse ha provocado incluso
cosas como está:
(El pasado marzo de 2018, el Ministro de Asuntos
Internos de Australia, Peter Dutton, anunció
públicamente que su país estudiaría conceder
con un visado especial de emergencia, refugio
a la población blanca sudafricana que se
sintiera insegura en su país)
[Un momento, un ministro australiano hablando
de dar cobijo a los blancos de sudáfrica.
¿Tan mal están las cosas? ¿No era este
el país de la armonía y la reconciliación?]
Pues amigos… tal cual como lo escucháis.
Pero llegados a este punto, la pregunta es…
¿Qué diantres salió mal?
Pues... podemos encontrar a un gran culpable
con nombre y apellidos. Ya os hablamos, por
cierto, de él en un vídeo que os dejo en
la descripción - ¿Sabéis quien es? Atentos.
JACOB ZUMA
El 9 de mayo de 2009, Jacob Zuma se convirtió
en el presidente de Sudáfrica.
A pesar de su controvertidos historial de
polémicas, con acusaciones de violación,
corrupción e incluso crimen organizado, que
se dice pronto, [¡Menuda joya!] Zuma consiguió
llegar al poder gracias al apoyo de las clases
populares... que le sentían como uno de los
suyos.
(Al fin y al cabo, estamos hablando de uno
de los líderes más destacados del movimiento
anti-apartheid, un líder que durante 10 años
compartió cárcel con el mismísimo Nelson
Mandela, el padre de la actual nación sudafricana.)
[No me diréis que es un mala carta de presentación]
Pues… amigos, Jacob Zuma, quien practica
abiertamente la poligamia y se calcula que
tiene al menos 20 hijos, se vio obligado a
dimitir por la puerta de atrás el pasado
14 de febrero de 2018.
(Repudiado por su propio partido, el poderoso
Congreso Nacional Africano; acorralado por
la oposición y amenazado con una moción
de censura no tuvo otra alternativa. Era marcharse
por las buenas o marcharse por las malas.
Y es que los casi 9 años que Zuma ha estado
en el poder, han sido toda una pesadilla para Sudáfrica.)
Veréis, Zuma llegó al poder con la promesa
de conseguir un país más próspero y con
más oportunidades para los más pobres, pero
en vez de eso… ¿que pensais que hizo?
Pues sí, ni más ni menos que convertir al
gobierno sudafricano en una especie de mina,
en un negocio particular a su servicio y al
servicio de su círculo.
[Por cierto, ¿Sabéis qué fue lo que primero
que hizo como Presidente? Pues…
gastarse 23, 23 millones de dólares del presupuesto
del estado en mejorar su residencia privada.
Una piscina por aquí, un anfiteatro por allí,
e Incluso, atentos, mandó construir un establo
para vacas y un gallinero. ¿Para qué diantres
querría un gallinero?]
(Pero, por supuesto, eso no es todo. El pasado
16 de marzo, la Fiscalia nacional anunció
que presentaría cargos contra Jacob Zuma
por un acuerdo multimillonario de compra de
armas, buques, submarinos y aviones de combate
que Sudáfrica firmó en los 90, cuando Zuma
era el presidente adjunto de Nelson Mandela,
con varias compañías europeas.)
Amigos, esta compra de armas superó los 3.000
millones de dólares. El objetivo declarado
mejorar la seguridad nacional. El objetivo
real, enriquecer a tipos como Jacob Zuma.
("El acuerdo para la compra de armas fue la
pérdida más gráfica de la inocencia de
Sudáfrica después del apartheid y presagiaba
la corrupción que estamos viendo hoy". David
Lewis, Director Ejecutivo de Corruption Watch,
una organización sin fines de lucro con sede
en Johannesburgo).
Y, ojo, este es solo un caso. Decenas y decenas
de casos más esperan su turno. [Sí, este
tipo fue muy, pero que muy avaricioso]
En total, se calcula que las mordidas y las
corruptelas de Zuma y su círculo le han costado
a las arcas públicas, ojo, más de 4 mil
millones de dólares estadounidenses.
Ahora bien, amigos, si pensais que esto es
lo peor estáis muy pero que muy equivocados.
Lo peor de todo es que hizo que el cancer
de la corrupción se extendiera masivamente
por todo el país. Atentos.
EL CÁNCER
Jacob Zuma siempre lo tuvo claro… y de hecho
lo dijo abiertamente… su partido, el Congreso
Nacional Africano era más importante que
la propia nación sudafricana.
Y qué mejor manera de poner por delante al
partido que haciendo de oro a sus líderes
con los recursos públicos.
[Sí,creo que esto me recuerdo mucho a algún
que otro político… ¿Se os ocurre a vosotros
algún nombre? ¿Quién es para vosotros el
político más corrupto? Dejadmelo en los
comentarios y abrimos debate]
Pero... continuemos. El caso es que dicho
y hecho.
(Desde que Zuma llegó al poder la corrupción
se ha disparado en todos los niveles: las
empresas estatales son un desastre, hay profesores
de matemáticas que no saben lo que es una
raíz cuadrada pero que son afiliados al partido
del expresidente - ya sabéis cómo consiguieron
el puesto - y prácticamente ninguna institución
se ha salvado de la corrupción.)
Fijaos, una forma de medir la intensidad de
la corrupción en Sudáfrica es fijarse en
la calidad de las viviendas que el gobierno
construye para los más pobres.
Tal cual como lo escucháis.
Si el presupuesto ya es bajo… cuando descontamos
lo que se llevan los políticos - ojo, no
solo dinero, también los propios materiales
de construcción - al final quedan casas de
tan mala calidad que algunas se han terminado
derrumbado.
(Otra forma muy habitual de “corrupción”
es apoderarse de los fondos para el desarrollo
de las zonas más pobres. Por ejemplo, para
granjas lecheras respaldadas por el gobierno.)
El caso más conocido es el de una granja
promovida directamente por Mosebenzi Zwane,
quien llegó a ser Ministro de Minería con
Zuma, claro.
Pues bien, un buen día este señor llegó
a una comunidad pobre y prometió construir
una granja lechera financiada por el gobierno.
Supuestamente la granja estaría controlada
por los trabajadores que se sumarán al proyecto,
a los cuales incluso les prometió un viaje
a la India para aprender a gestionar esta
explotación
[¿un viaje a la India para aprender a gestionar
vacas. Ya empezaba mal la cosa]
(“Dijo que quería cambiar nuestras vidas.
Nos dijo que este proyecto venía del gobierno,
que no tendría coste alguno, que no podía
no gustarnos. Nos dijo que debíamos sumarnos”
Ephraim Dhlamini, agricultor que se apuntó
para formar parte de la granja)
Al final el gobierno se gastó 23 millones
de dólares, los únicos que se fueron de
viaje fueron los miembros del coro de la Iglesia
de este político y por supuesto él se hizo
de oro.
De la granja… bueno, no está claro si se
llegó a ordeñar alguna vaca.
Y esto es solo un ejemplo de cientos. En los
últimos años miles de millones para el desarrollo
han sido desviados, “perdidos”, por los
líderes del partido en el poder.
(Cómo os podéis imaginar todo esto ha causado
un gran daño económico. Eso de invertir
en un país donde el político de turno puede
poner la mano, o donde las cuentas públicas
están fatal… digamos que no hace mucha
gracia.)
Pero ahora… tras la dimisión obligada de
Jacob Zuma [en su partido se estaban poniendo
nerviosos de cara a las siguientes elecciones]
… la pregunta es… ¿Cambiará el nuevo
gobierno las cosas?
¿EL CAMBIO?
El 15 de febrero de 2018, tras la dimisión
de Jacob Zuma, Cyril Ramaphosa otro histórico
líder del movimiento anti apartheid fue nombrado
presidente.
No hablamos de un tipo cualquiera. El Sr.
Ramaphosa dejó la política a finales de
la década de los 90 para dar el salto al
mundo de los negocios.
¿Y sabéis qué? Gracias a sus influencias
y a empresarios blancos que querían tener
buenas relaciones con el gobierno, Ramaphosa
logró convertirse en uno de los hombres más
ricos del África Subsahariana.
Su fortuna actual se estima en cerca de 500
millones de dólares.
(Pues bien, este nuevo presidente ha prometido
un “nuevo amanecer”. Según ha dicho,
su política tendrá como prioridades, equilibrar
las cuentas públicas, atraer inversión y
luchar contra la corrupción.
Su lema: “Sudáfrica está abierta a los
negocios”.)
Claro que de entrada ya se enfrenta algún
que otro problema… por ejemplo, la Asamblea
Nacional aprobó en marzo poner en marcha
el proceso para cambiar la Constitución,
de tal forma que el gobierno pueda expropiar
sin compensación la tierra en manos de la
población blanca.
Y amigos, si finalmente llevan esto a cabo…
está claro que la inversión no va a llegar…
va a salir corriendo.
Pero en fin solo el tiempo podrá decirnos
si este nuevo gobierno logra que Sudáfrica
se sume a los leones que están despertando
o por contra, el país continúa por la senda
del abismo.
Pero ahora turno para ti, ¿Crees que tu gobierno,
el gobierno de tu país lucha suficientemente
contra la corrupción? Déjanos tu respuesta
en los comentarios y también en esta encuesta.
Si te ha resultado interesante el vídeo dale
a like y no olvides suscribirte a VisualPolitik.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.